alors on va aller directement on va
aller directement à l'affiche est-ce que
la fille voilà Thomas est-ce que vous
avez la refaire vous avez la f euh non
je suis un peu nul en rêve ah bon Laura
d'accord ah oui je vois ça y est Thomas
ça s'appelle donc un glory hole
comment expliquer ce que c'est à une
heure de grande écoute Laura en fait
non non non non non
comment on explique à une heure de
grande écoute son Alice sur Google
Images
alors moi j'explique dans le spectacle
pour le coup donc j'explique vraiment le
l'origine de la fiche et de l'idée de
cette
affiche et je pense que voilà c'est le
mieux c'est de venir voir le spectacle
pour éviter d'être choqué pour les sur
les images